the one thing I like about Gary his
honesty it's a really good person he
always tells the truth you know I've
never had a meeting with Gary I was like
whoa I wonder what he really thought
it's like I know exactly what he thought
and he helped me realize what I wanted
to think - what's up Rob Clark's group
it's Gary Vee appreciate all of you hope
you guys are fired up about the book I
think they're gonna be blown away
tried really hard my son was interesting
I hope they get they hope you get the
video for all of you guys which is such
an exciting night definitely felt like
my strongest book opening you know big
event interesting environment
like Dar 101 Stef is such a great
interviewer that's why I requested her
she crushed it she you know she leaves
no breathing room you got to bring your
A game so I was happy about that I've
built a company that is a machine not me
that can deliver on the KPI for several
different reasons first and foremost
Madison Avenue agencies are not good at
what they do in a 2016 world and there's
an enormous white space we answer it yes
sis I'm on stage why isn't she here why
aren't you here I love you more love you
more
so so I'm able to do you want to come
she didn't want to come to doing it calm
okay
hello yeah that's right it's right
better that you get you know so Gary let
us hear what I'll teach John Haley good
to see you brother
how are you good good man
some guys how are you man good to see
you thank you thank you very excited
about hanging out and doing all the book
signing stuff and selfies you know the
guys at the end were like man you really
nice some like of course thanks for
coming first amazing it's so funny I it
blows my mind every time I do those
things where people like oh you're nice
and you really like your fans I'm like
yes what's the what's the alternative
they're like oh everybody else then it's
just so crazy to me it's crazy to me
please a couple of you are going to
break out follow this blueprint win
become something have people admire you
and care about you want to take a selfie
want to get the book signed please
please don't become that person that
ever takes it for granted remember where
you came from I'm on anchor because of
you it's awesome
killing it good for you man keep going
at it except remember where you came
from it really matters never never ever
lose that gratitude of another even even
we have four people following you right
now
never you know never lose the gratitude
for those four and I think it's very
easy and so that's that's kind of the
memorable moment Iraq how many people
want to be aligned with after watching
me talk for an hour or answer questions
wanted to stay in line for an hour and a
half to get a selfie are you kidding me
that uh that's the greatest high in the
world
my name is Ari Levine I'm the head of
new business in vaynermedia I help us
help people sell [ __ ] so I sell [ __ ] to
people who want to sell [ __ ] and make
money for vaynermedia I came more from
the startup world so I worked at tumblr
I worked at a company called StumbleUpon
and I love vaynermedia not because it's
an agency but because it's an
entrepreneurial startup hustle fest
works when we Gary so it's a whirlwind
it's nonstop it's always moving it's
always learning it's quick decisions and
having fun going to do a podcast James
Altucher show d-roc is doing daily fit
we are rocking snapchat follow me I'm
about to get real serious on it the rock
I want right here you know like the QR
code pause it right now take a picture
of that to follow me put the link in the
show the snapchat add me snapchat a lot
of you're messing up it's stunning how
many of you I just put it on Instagram
and like 40 people that I'm engaging
with all the time like just added you
the [ __ ] are you waiting for
hey it's Mike Boyd I manage the few
artists are unfortunate Ritchie saw
though uh and I know Gary because I've
been working with him for about eight
years and AJ I met AJ in college I met
Gary when I moved to New York City 2009
I've been telling Gary through AJ who
was hot which hip-hop artists were about
to pop and when I moved to New York City
Gary tweeted out if you're a real
hustler and you want to make money and
you're about that lifestyle hit me up
until I hit a jazz I'll have to meet
your brother bro dad met Gary he offered
me a job I took it I'm in New York just
had a meeting with Gary about to go to
LA tomorrow with Richie style my
producer my artist album dropped last
week things are crazy but things are
good yeah just trying to make something
big happen with Gary man
put it all together hey James thank you
how are you brother is a it's great to
see ya thanks for coming in thanks for
having me
where we going get here okay yes well
firstly nice to meet you
well hi Paul this how are you pleasure -
Gary benefit are you produce or should
help me prepare awesome so we have the
whole team here amazing right there
let's do it it seems like there's a
direct path which is learned then create
a great content then create community
around that content then have calls to
action for people to buy and that's what
you've done really successfully with
wine
yes spent 10 years learning yes created
content which is the wine library yes
maybe around that yes call to action by
this one yes and you're honest about it
every step of the way yes and and and
the same thing with social media that's
how these yes what's come about yeah so
what if somebody says oh my god that
could take like 20 years or 15 years
like it took Gary yes or 10 years or yes
I speed up the process I don't think
anything valuable comes fast and so I
just think that my method is much more
tried-and-true there's a lot more of the
Gary Vaynerchuk success story than the
overnight 24 months everything happened
for you success story right so so in a
lot of the content marketing I think the
key is establishing that trust so you
can build community so the community
goes from whatever they were at before
it so oh no here's the guy I can
actually trust and that involves a
certain type of sincerity as opposed to
here are the top 10 things you know need
to know about wine you kind of have to
start off with here's what I didn't know
about wine now here's what I'm learning
so how do you how do you kind of like
break into sincerity because I think
that is the real challenge for a lot of
content marketers there's big marketing
I think that's right that's right and I
think you've got a peg I think the North
Star has to be truth I mean it's it's
quite simple how do you know it for
years like let's say someone starts out
they might not have all the knowledge
but they don't know how do they know
they're being sincere like where's the
line what are they oh I think that I
think it's not tightly Christian Sarah I
know but I don't I don't think you know
look if you do not know what the truth
or not the truth is within your own body
of your own self well then there's
nothing I can do or you can do to help
anybody I would
99% of the people know the truth when
you come out the gate and you're 23
years old and you want to be a life
coach you know that you haven't lived
life yet it's not super complicated like
like when you want to teach people how
to make money on 23 because somebody
who's 53 told you this is the quick way
to make money but you know that you've
never made money like you know that to
be true okay I'll take it
yeah thank you thank you
real pleasure it's okay Samantha [ __ ]
that [ __ ] yes
good hustle suddenly and how are you how
are you man nice to meet you nice to
meet you what's cooking
um just hanging on New York real from
Philly yep what you guys use here they
figured it they think you like a little
bit thank you okay Oh something new for
you my and they thought they saw that
yeah because of the picture I took on
the pad yeah good hustle real good
hustle I love it you guys I'm running
late for something but you want quick
pictures or some like that what do you
guys about what do you guys what do you
guys do at work marketing yep big one
social media yep I love you thank you
thank you thank you brother let's do it
we're doing a video or picture this
little just big oh that's a good I get
one more all right all right thanks so
much
no worries man yeah got it gonna do a
selfie one yeah you got hairy I'm gonna
say so love you brother
going to see I'll see you soon looking
forward to thank you fearful what was
your name again
I'm s j SJ yeah that's J yesterday like
that d-roc I need initials what's up man
Jacob Jacob meet you whose ticket we're
doing selfie first yeah that's it Shay
don't [ __ ] up Ellis thank you so much a
platter I wish you well good luck to you
thank you for what you guys keep doing
it too got a long way to go do you think
thanks for having me real nice to meet
you yes they will thanks for having me
enjoy the rest week
take care yeah
although we could do some signing
Visionnaire yeah I want everybody here
kind of listening to me and thinking
about what these things that I'm saying
meaning to their disciplines right the
askgaryvee book account i want looking
at all
coms starting right away i don't know
when everybody goes on spring break
probably starts next week of people
saying like getting excited for vacation
getting you know getting excited for my
spring break and i want to reply to them
and say surprise you've won this and i
want it to be like you won yeah we're
gonna send you the askgaryvee book doing
and then have a hashtag like spring
break book or whatever we come up with
Lauren
Norris it recive Carrie what you meeting
today I'll pass I get it
that's amazing photo machine thank you
because I'm not gonna be able
communicate with you guys come forward
Andy what's what's most important okay
let's see we're literally the show is we
just have halt like you just get there
and like once a month third Thursday of
every month at the Beacon Theater it can
become like a thing
it's like a comedian or Billy Joel at
the garden just like that just like I
really think I'll do the I'm pretty
thing that I'll do the garden in a QA
fill it the whole thing
mark my words honey all seven years no
seriously it's gonna take me something
like I have to I have to do something
like Netflix or snapchat show I'm gonna
need that moment you know but I fully
believe it's gonna happen you want you
aigis residence you Vegas I would do it
in Vegas and heartbeat how we doing
[ __ ] every night I [ __ ] love that
I could so do that just literal I can do
it in one second just get on stage and
like here we go
and just go
day before the book midday still so much
[ __ ] that we didn't get to you're always
leaving something on the table on these
promotions like months ago you even with
the whole team of billion people on the
team we're still left a lot on table and
that's just the way it is a lot of times
can't get to everything but the effort
was there and so happy
hello yes I'm here to see Ivanka who are
you I am Gary Vaynerchuk
ah how are you and do you welcome see
you I feel like going good to see you
explain get that a lot I'll quit so
weird I mean how are you so funny
I'm good how you feeling it um I feel
very pregnant so I might do like now
basically what we're doing the child in
the middle of this that'd be really good
yeah I gotta then I would need you there
ste right but you have to take a picture
yes you ask you you're the doctor right
that's right um she's watching YouTube
it's not coming she's not as
knowledgeable she does know that I have
stuff but I was literally walking in my
kitchen and I hear her go now subscribe
down below and I was just like this is
so cool so crazy so crazy film it all at
home like do you think oh there's
there's literally you can't even find
pictures of my wife or my kids Lizzie
and I've gone really dark there and then
everything else is in the open I guess
because it's so extreme you know what it
is I think it's a person I mean honestly
I think it's I think it's um I truly
think it's a one by one by one
individual you know decision in the
meaning it's important for her and it's
important for me I want my kids to
decide how they want to play like if
Misha wants to have a youtube show
tomorrow that's more interesting to let
her I didn't want her I didn't want to
force that on her but it's I don't you
know what I don't judge how to turn off
yes it's good for me I like that but you
know what honestly like right now
because of this I've been getting
pounded on work-life balance because I'm
truly working 18 hours a day yeah and I
don't think people believed me and now
that there's no wiggle room and it's
truth people are bashing me a little bit
for like not being home and and I I tell
them I'm like look they don't know that
you know I came to this country with
nothing and my dad work every day they
don't live the life that I didn't even
know who he was until I was 15 because
he literally left before I woke up and
literally got home when I went this
after I went to sleep and they don't
know that Lizzy's dad was very
successful corporate guy and traveled a
boatload so for us it's weirdly normal
you know you can't you can't impose like
how to you can't tell people how to
raise their kids and you can you don't
know people's work/life balance are
migrated a hundred percent the book
comes out tomorrow which I'm super
excited about so if you want to send me
any like any yeah okay thank you so much
I will not forget um I think you're
super good you know I was pumped I was
pumping you got to hang out with Casey
he's amazing he is awesome the best love
that guy he's the best he actually ate
between the two of you I don't know
who's higher energy but we are higher
we've done a couple episodes together
and like the screen explodes yeah I
don't even know how that was but we're
gonna do a I didn't tell you I don't
think I don't think I told you Casey and
I are gonna do a collaborated vlog day
where we're both gonna walk around and
that I knew I didn't tell you this is
this is what I get to tell you we're
gonna like just cross sync them and it's
gonna be his yeah it's gonna be amazing
but he's he's amazing if I were you
again and you might recall this was my
thesis on you different than Casey and I
that grew up from that world you're an
actual like real-life entity which makes
when you go in there Oh triple good
okay got it I mean you know what I got
way rather than a QA that yes I you know
what I'm dying for no makeup real life
like you know I know you got I know you
got it you got to you you got to do you
but anything that's just like link
literally what I think you can crush on
Facebook live and this is where it's
gonna go random random like just like
hey just had a great meeting or hate
like it's a big deal interesting that
Kip it's just look look that's winning
on people believing what whether they
agree with what he says or disagree they
believe he believes it he was there for
a second
alright need Rosano you want brother I
like the way you roll with that clever
kind of picture and there's me jumping
in you're the winner of the giveaway
reddit fans one hour away from mic hey
ma come hit me read it let me read it
so ya can see it yes hi man
yeah I'm literally here actually I'm
walking in the door and I'm gonna go PLC
in a second we are clearly in bluff mode
right now this is the night before the
big day tomorrow
it drops like it I was gonna say like a
top it I don't like that
it drops tomorrow I'm very very proud
the early reviews are in and it's widely
considered one of the great literally
example at a literal literal what is it
the literary examples of business in
modern time according to tomorrow
Vaynerchuk mother of guaranteed a check
and this is actually like a very
one-on-one personal thing if you can get
anybody and I mean like your boy from
around the way or like your girlfriend
like anybody that wants to support me
tomorrow buying it bookstores and Barnes
and Nobles matters way more like we're
done with them like if you like
literally on a one-to-one i'm on
everybody listening on a one-to-one
basis like that would mean a lot headed
to CNN really just want to talk about
New York Jets for agency but I think
we're gonna be pushing me towards
politics I guess I should have booked
SportsCenter
so up Instagram in the green room on CNN
in CNN at CNN about to go on CNN 10:45
Eastern check it how do you think social
media is changing the game I know it
seems like a broad question but how do
you think there it's just a tension
arbitrage I mean you can't reach an
under 25 year old in America unless
you're on Instagram and snapchat like
that's a factor like it's just attention
ARB this is always what's happened if
you really want to go back to what
happened between radio and television
that's really the biggest con to this
what's going on right now we are living
through a massive communication shift in
society and people are grossly under
estimating it